لمزيد من المتابعه معنا من خان يونس
مراسلنا اسماعيل ابو عمر اسماعيل اذا لعل
الصوره اوضح لديك بخصوص ما جرى مع
النازحين الذين استهدفوا وهم يجبرون على
مغادره مدرستي الشيخ جبر وقنديل في خان
يونس نعم ساعات صعبه وايام صعبه مرت على
النازحين سواء في مدرستي الشيخ جبر وقنديل
وكذلك في مدارس او تجمع مدارس العوده في
مناطق شرق محافظه خمش ايضا هم كذلك في هذه
اللحظات معرضون لحصار خانق من قبل اليات
الاحتلال وتطلق اليات الاحتلال وسيارات
الاحتلال النار بتجاه هؤلاء النازحين في
المدارس التي ذكرناها قنديله والشيخ جبر
استشهد سبعه مواطنين بينهم ثلاثه من
المسنين نتيجه اطلاق النار من قبل قناصه
الاحتلال بينما كان يحاول هؤلاء النازحون
التوجه حسب تعليمات جيش الاسرائيلي في تلك
المنطقه باتجاه جامعه الاقصى والتوجه الى
منطقه المواصي ومنها الى التحرك سواء وسط
قطاع غزه او جنوب قطاع غزه الى مدينه رفح
لكن قوات الاحتلال قامت باطلاق النار
باتجاه هؤلاء النازحين مما اوقع سبعه
شهداء حتى اللحظه اضافه الى عده اصابات في
صفوف هؤلاء النازحين حينما وصل النازحون
الى تلك المنطقه التي حددتها قوات
الاحتلال وجدوا اليات الاحتلال تغلق
الطريق بعضهم عاد ادراجه الى مستشفى ناصر
ونزح الى مستشفى ناصر في ظل ظروف صعبه
ايضا يحياها ويعيشها هذا المستشفى نتيجه
هذا الحصار المستمر واطلاق النار المستمر
من قبل اليات الاحتلال نتحدث بان هنا هناك
مخاوف كبيره على المواطنين داخل المستشفى
في ظل اطلاق النار كذلك الظروف الماساويه
بسبب الحصار المستمر وعدم وصول امدادات
المياه امدادات الغذاء لهذا المستشفى كذلك
امدادات الوقود التي تشغل المولدات
الكهربائيه خاصه نتحدث بان خلال الساعات
القادمه القليله القريبه
سيتم اقفال ووقف تشغيل المولدات
الكهربائيه في مستشفى ناصر ما يعرض حياه
عشرات بمئات المواطنين سواء من المرضى
وكذلك كوادر الطبيه والنازحين داخل مستشف
لخطر الشديد في المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه
خيوس تجمع مدارس العوده تحديدا مدرسه
المتنبي وغيره من هذه المدارس تحاصر اليات
الاحتلال قامت قبل قليل جرافات الاحتلال
بتدمير السور الخارجي لمدرسه المتنبي من
الناحيه الشماليه وما زالت تقوم باعمال
تجريف حتى هذه اللحظه هناك شهيدان في صفوف
المواطنين او النازحين في تلك في محيط تلك
المدارس ما زالت جثمانيهما ملقا على الارض
لا تستطيع الطواقم ولا حتى المواطنين
المتواجدين داخل هذه المدارس انتشال ونقل
هذين الشهيدين الى داخل المدرسه ليتم
دفنهما داخل المدرسه ك على شبيه ما حدث
خلال الايام الماضيه من دفن شهداء داخل
مدارس العوده بعد ان يتم استهدافهم من قبل
قوات الاحتلال سواء باطلاق النار من قبل
المسيرات او حتى من اليات الاحتلال
المتمركزه بالقرب من هذه المدارس هناك
اصابه ايضا في صفوف النازحين داخل مدارس
العوده
يتم معالجتها داخل المدرسه من قبل طواقم
طبيه موجوده داخل المستشف المدرسه عفوا
ابو عمر كنت معنا من خان يونس شكرا جزيلا
لك